diese acht männer besitzen gleich viel
vermögen wie die ärmere hälfte der
weltbevölkerung
also gleich viel wie 3,6 milliarden
menschen zusammen für viele von uns geht
das zu weit
doch wie viel ungleichheit verträgt
unsere gesellschaft und ist das ideal
der chancengleichheit nicht eine naive
utopie
darüber spreche ich mit der philosophie
und ökonomie lisa herzog
sie meint zu viel ungleichheit schafft
privilegien für reiche und raubt uns
letztlich die freiheit verhetzung
herzlich willkommen
herzlichen dank ja kein geringerer aus
barack obama hatte vor kurzem dass die
ungleichheit die größte gefahr darstellt
für unsere demokratien wie kann denn
wirtschaftliche ungleichheit die
demokratie bedrohen demokratie beruht
auf dem gedanken dass jeder einzelne den
gleichen moralischen status hat und auch
in gleicher weise an der gesetzgebung
beteiligt sein soll
ungleichheit per se müsste nicht
gefährlich sein denn wir sind alle
ungleich jeder von uns hat andere
interessen und talente aber wenn
ungleichheit ein gewisses maß
überschreitet dann gefährdet sie diese
annahme dass wir wirklich moralisch
gesehen alle gleich und gleich wertvoll
sind können sie ein beispiel machen
inwiefern der unterschied zwischen arm
und reich und dazu groß wird irgendwie
ein dass die demokratie gefährden kann
eine frage ist wie sie mit geld einfluss
auf politik nehmen können
der demokratietheorie gemäss sollte der
einfluss alle bürgerinnen und bürger
gleich sein aber wenn sie sich die
heutige welt anschauen dann ist es so
dass in vielen ländern mit geld einfluss
auf politik ausgeübt werden kann und
dass sie auch in vielen anderen
gesellschaftlichen bereichen sei es vor
gericht sei es bei der bildung und
erziehung ihrer kinder vorteile haben
wenn sie über geld verfügen
also wenn geld nur zu dazu da wäre luxus
güter zu kaufen wäre es vielleicht gar
nicht so ein problem aber geld kann eben
auch sehr viele andere dinge ermöglichen
und auch in ländern wie deutschland oder
der schweiz
ich denke wir nähern uns der
gefährlichen ausmaßen der ungleichheit
was sowohl am oberen als auch am unteren
spektrum zu
beobachten ist was man dabei allerdings
auch beachten muss ist dass ungleichheit
nicht nur die finanzielle dimension hat
sondern auch viel damit zu tun hat in
was für lebenswelten die menschen
eigentlich unterwegs sind wie viel
absicherungen sie in ihrem leben haben
welche arten von jobs sie und ihre
kinder bekommen können das sind alles
dimensionen von ungleichheit die man
auch mitdenken muss und die letztlich
darüber bestimmen in welchem maß man ein
neues selbstbestimmtes leben führen kann
der britische politologe colin crouch
gingen sogar so weit zu sagen dass wir
in einer post demokratie leben in einer
scheindemokratie eigentlich wo wir
glauben wir können mitbestimmen aber
eigentlich ist es eine kleine elite aus
politik und wirtschaft die die fäden
zieht würden sie auch so weit gehen
nicht für deutschland und die schweiz
ist ein dritter und sie gerade gesagt in
großbritannien und den usa fragt man
sich schon sehr und gerade den usa ist
es ja so dass parteispenden eine ganz
große auswahl kommen auch die politik
haben und ironischerweise war es jetzt
so dass ein präsident
schamp deswegen gewählt wurde weil man
sagte der ist so reicht der muss kein
geld von anderen annehmen um gewählt
werden zu können was ja schon die zweite
stufe der perversion ist sozusagen also
wird diese länder kann man wirklich
nicht mehr von der sauberen stabilen
demokratie sprechen
aber was tut man dagegen als stichwort
parteispenden oder kampagnen spenden
schaut man da transparenz oder verbietet
man dass diese sind im moment denke ich
an dem punkt wo die transparenz sehr
stark gewachsen ist und das ist sicher
gut so früher gab es die auch einflüsse
vielleicht auch aber man hat sie nicht
wahrgenommen weil man sich wusste was
ein hinterzimmer passiert ist
transparenz allein reicht aber nicht
notwendigerweise aus um wirklich etwas
zu ändern
den usa ist eines der probleme dass
parteispenden unter die meinungsfreiheit
fallen und dort deswegen mit geschützt
sind und deswegen ist es nicht so
einfach ist doch was dagegen zu machen
aber von der theoretischen man auch
keine philosophischen seite her ist es
relativ klar dass man diesen einfluss
von geld auf politik begrenzen sollte
jetzt erleben wir derzeit ein phänomen
mit zunehmenden nationalismus und
populismus kann man sagen dass die
ungleichheit die acht zugenommen hat
irgendwie diesen siegeszug des
populismus begünstigt hat das scheint
schon so zu sein wobei das sicher nicht
die einzige ursache ist was gerade in
deutschland auffällig ist das ist dass
dieses gefühl der unsicherheit dass man
sozial abrutschen könnte sich offenbar
bis weit in die mittelschicht hinein
verbreitet das heißt es ist vielleicht
nicht mal die ungleich einem an sich
sondern die frage wer in der
gesellschaft sein status einigermaßen
absichern kann also gehört absichert und
nur den reichen sozusagen
und auch die frage wie kann ich mich
eigentlich in die gesellschaft
einbringen was auch damit zu tun hat
welche arten von arbeit eigentlich für
welche personengruppen offen sind und
das hat einerseits die monetäre
dimension also wie viel kann ich
verdienen aber auch die situation die
die dimension der langfristigen
lebensplanung kann ich eigentlich
dauerhafte jobs haben kann ich jobs
haben die auch gute arbeit darstellen
und ich mich entwickeln kann und so
weiter das sind alles dinge wo man
anscheinend das gefühl hat es ist nicht
mehr so selbstverständlich dass es
funktioniert und dazu kommt vielleicht
auch noch dieses gefühl dass der
mainstream der politik in den letzten
jahren immer wieder argumentiert hat da
kann man nichts ändern die wirtschaft
ist wie sie ist es gibt keine
alternative wie man das feature das
formuliert hat und das was so ein gefühl
des fatalismus erzeugt hat und
populisten behaupten sie könnten etwas
dagegen tun ob sie das wirklich können
dass eine ganz andere frage aber dieser
wille sich zu wehren endlich wieder
dinge in die hand zu nehmen
das scheinen gewissen reiz zu haben und
kann man etwas dagegen tun
ich denke ja ich denke dass die politik
in den letzten jahren sehr stark davon
geprägt war zu glauben die
globalisierung lässt sich weder
aufhalten noch steuern
aber das ist überhaupt nicht gesagt dass
das so ist denn die systeme mit denen
wir es hier zu tun haben sind wirklich
menschen gemacht das system da geht es
um rechtliche fragen da geht es um
institutionen wie zum beispiel die
welthandelsorganisation in
weltwährungsfonds
das ist nicht naturgegeben und deswegen
ist immer die frage wie lassen
das gestalten trotzdem vom gefühl her
sind ja so ein kleines rädchen in einem
riesen system und unser beitrag ist ein
tropfen auf einen heißen stein
was vielleicht auch einfach eine
wahrnehmung sache ist weil wir jetzt
sehen wie groß und komplexe system
eigentlich ist das war es vorher
vielleicht auch aber wir haben es nicht
so wahrgenommen
trotzdem würde ich sagen das heißt nicht
dass es keine handlungsoptionen gibt und
zwar sowohl für den einzelnen wie sie es
formuliert haben als auch für die
politik die impulse geben kann was ich
vielleicht geändert hat das ist dass man
für sehr viele probleme der heutigen
welt nicht mehr nur für sich alleine
erfolge erwirken kann sondern muss sich
zusammentun mit anderen man müsse
gemeinschaftlich handeln und auch
staaten müssen gemeinsam gibt es
probleme angehen zum beispiel
steuerschlupflöcher schließen stichwort
panama papers warum dort bis heute
nichts passiert das verstehe ich einfach
überhaupt nicht aber das sind dinge wo
ein einzelner staat alleine sicher
probleme haben wird
aber es gibt ja auch die oecd und solche
organisationen die könnten da gemeinsam
durchaus dinge bewegen weil wir in einem
globalen markt leben und einer alleine
kann das nicht machen wenn andere
tiefere steuern anbietet dann geht das
chaos dahin wettbewerb und das kapital
fließt dann möglicherweise dorthin wo
die steuern niedriger sind und bei
natürlich auch immer die frage ist was
für eine art von kapital ist das jetzt
bei finanzkapitals einfach angelegt wird
geht es vielleicht wirklich nur um die
höhe der verzinsung oder der besteuerung
und so wenn es um produktives capital
geht es darum geht wirklich zu
investieren wert zu schaffen ist
natürlich immer auch die frage was sind
denn eigentlich die damen bedingungen in
den ländern was bietet man dem kapital
sozusagen an und vielleicht müsste man
auch einfach sehr viel stärker betonen
dass eine gut ausgebildete
arbeitnehmerschaft die auch langfristig
an der wertschöpfung teilhaben will auch
ein wert ist und das immer nur kosten
sparen vielleicht nicht der einzige
punkt ist der entscheidend dafür sein
sollte wohin investitionen gehen ich
gerade mit einer langfristigen
perspektive nicht interessiert nach
diese mittelschicht die sie erwähnt
haben das hat sich verändert also diese
angst abzurutschen in die unterschicht
gelegen zu verlieren warum hat das
zugenommen in den letzten zehn jahren
und 20 jahren also ich bin keine
empirische sozialwissenschaftlerin
gesagt ich kann nur weitergeben was ich
selber lese was einst ein problem zu
sein scheint ist dass es gleich spaltung
des arbeitsmarkts gibt in einerseits die
dauerhaften stabilen jobs und dann aber
auch sehr viele befristete jobs
kurzfristige jobs wo man wenig
planungssicherheit hat wo vielleicht gar
nicht das einzige problem ist dass man
wenig verdient sondern dass es so schwer
wird langfristig das eigene leben zu
planen und eine gewisse sicherheit zu
haben und ich denke das ist einer der
wesentlichen faktoren dafür ein anderer
punkt ist natürlich dass in den
westlichen ländern gerade für die untere
mittelschicht die einkommen in den
letzten jahrzehnten kaum gewachsen sind
im schnitt während an der spitze der
vermögensverteilung steil nach oben ging
und global gesehen gab es auch
entwicklungen die für viele positiv
waren aber diese unteren bis mittleren
mittelschicht westlichen staaten das war
nicht unbedingt die größten gewinner der
globalisierung das ist ein ganz
zentraler punkt und der serbisch
amerikanische ökonom branco milanovic
hat eine grafik erstellt die auf den
ersten blick ein bisschen kompliziert
ist aber man sieht einen elefanten darin
der sozusagen rechts mit dem rüssel nach
unten geht und dann wieder hoch und was
jetzt angesprochen haben dass die
mittelschicht der reicheren westlichen
länder verloren hat in der
globalisierung vorraum in den jahren 88
bis 2008 in der heißen phase der
globalisierung vor dem crash sieht man
an diesen knick bei ihm bei dem 80
patienten und vielleicht kann sie kurz
erläutern was man hier wo sie sehen kann
also das ganze vielleicht noch kurz
vorab stellt eigentlich das wachstum der
einkommen
global gesehen fällt das heißt
korrigiert für inflation und ganz rechts
wäre wahrscheinlich
irgendwie bill gates oder marc st das
hier sind die herren die sie im übrigen
alles herren die sie am anfang gezeigt
haben und dass hier sozusagen die
weltbevölkerung aufgereiht nach ihrem
einkommen einkommen nicht vermögen das
ist auch eine wichtige unterscheidung an
der stelle das hier sieht einkommen und
und dieser große berge sozusagen das
genau war das elephant das ist ein ganz
großer teil der weltbevölkerung der
relativ arm war der aber klose zuwächse
hatte asien indien china sind hier ganz
wichtig auch die die so genannten bric
länder also brasilien russland indien
china
die haben von den entwicklungen der
letzten jahrzehnte profitiert das waren
teilweise sehr sehr hohe zu wechseln
und hier wird es dann eben dünner
beziehungsweise hier geht es sogar ins
negative
das ist ein teil dieser menschen die
haben real verloren und die spitze geht
dann wieder ganz stark nach oben das
heißt eine spitze der
einkommensverteilung ganz enorme
zuwächse
der autor beschreibt insgesamt ist die
welt heute ökonomisch betrachtet ein
gerechter ein gerechterer ort als früher
das macht die globalisierung die welt
insgesamt besser
das bezieht er auf die welt als ganzes
und damit meint er vor allem diesen berg
hier und nicht unbedingt den rüssel das
elefanten also genügt die millionäre
dass diese bevölkerungsgruppen zuwächse
hatten ist natürlich aus gerechtigkeit
perspektive großartig
die sage ist trotzdem wie geht man damit
um dass innerhalb einzelner länder die
nun mal die wichtigste politische
steuerungseinheit sind und das einkommen
sehr unterschiedlich ist und auch gerade
das vermögen auch sehr ungleich verteilt
ist und man ja gemeinsam in diesen
staaten gerade in einer demokratie
irgendwie gesetze erlassen will
politische prozesse anstoßen will sich
an die globalisierung auch anpassen will
und wenn da die schere immer weiter
aufgeht entstehen probleme auch wenn am
rest der welt dinge passieren die wir
eigentlich gut halten würden und das
zeigte ja auch in sein buch die
ungleiche welt das nämlich nicht nur die
einkommen
verteilung oder die ungleichheit der
einkommen global abgenommen hat sondern
die ungleichheit china haut zu starten
hat eben zugenommen ja warum ist das so
ist wieder eine empirische frage
letztlich es gibt unterschiedliche
faktoren die aufgelistet werden
eine ganz entscheidende frage ist was
für arten von jobs es gibt und eine
diskussion die da immer geführt wird ist
eben inwieweit jobs in der produktion
der unteren mittelschicht weltweit sich
verlagert haben also wir kaufen sehr
viele dinge eben aus indien china all
diesen ländern die gewonnen haben wie
sie jobs haben wir hier verloren
vieles davon haben wir verloren wobei da
die usa und england auch noch mal anders
dastehen als deutschland und die schweiz
weil ich hier noch relativ in produktion
stattfindet und vergleich während gerade
in den usa sehr viele
dienstleistungsjobs übrig geblieben sind
aber gerade im so genannten postpaid so
legendär die autoindustrie dort die hat
eben sehr darunter gelitten und das ist
einer der gründe dafür wieso hier
gesellschaftlich eine stagnation
stattgefunden hat und die jobs die
stattdessen entstanden sind auch von
vielen nicht also gute jobs und soviel
aussichten mit so gutem einkommen
empfunden werden und auch oft nicht sinn
wie das was da verloren gegangen ist und
wenn wir ein bisschen in die zukunft
blicken verschärft sich das spitzt sich
das zu
das dürfte maßgeblich davon abhängen wie
das politisch gestaltet wird ich meine
schauen würde ja die globalisierung
zurücktreten
und er scheint irgendwie live
vorstellung zu haben dass es da in der
vergangenheit verlierer und gewinner gab
und wenn man es jetzt zurück dreht dann
werden aus dem damaligen verlierern
wieder gewinner so funktioniert die
wirtschaft nicht unbedingt das ist
überhaupt nicht gesagt dass man diese
jobs zurückholen kann oder auch sollte
die frage ist welche anderen
möglichkeiten gibt es um jobs zu
schaffen die in diesem bereich den
leuten und gutes stabiles einkommen
sichern
und da könnte was der ganze reihe von
faktoren auflisten die rolle der
gewerkschaften die rolle von
betrieblicher mitbestimmung sagen nach
dem kündigungsschutz fragen danach in
welche sektoren eigentlich investitionen
fließen in welchem maß des staates
vielleicht auch teilweise mit steuert
anwalt setzt in bestimmte bereiche zu
gehen in deutschland gibt es den
vorschlag managergehälter ab einer
bestimmten höhe nicht mehr steuerlich
absetzbar zu machen und da oben eine
gewisse bremse anzulegen also ist es
nicht so dass es keine möglichkeiten
gäbe und es gibt auch die mehr
vorschläge die von ökonomen und
soziologen optisch gelegt wurden
die frage ist gibt es den politischen
willen diese dinge anzugehen
ich möchte noch kurz aber ein autor zu
sprechen kommen den französischen
ökonomen thoma bietet interessante
erklärung dafür sagte die kapitalrendite
hat einen sehr stark zugenommen stärker
auf das wirtschaftswachstum
das heißt geld verdient man mehr geld
aus mitarbeit und das sagt er ist das
problem dass uns auch teil des problems
aber das erklärt natürlich nicht was
rein auf der ebene der arbeitseinkommen
basiert und da gab es ja auch großer
veränderungen bei der vermögensbildung
erweckt man vielleicht den eindruck dass
das irgendwie so naturgesetz zu sein
dass ein stein gemeißelt dass seien
unaufschiebbare tendenzen aber auch das
ist nicht so denn auch hier gibt es die
möglichkeit der besteuerung der
regulierung und was da im moment eben
eine der dringlichsten aufgaben werde
dass wir eine internationale abstimmung
um besteuerung des kapitals zu
vereinheitlichen und gewisse
schlupflöcher zu schließen denn sonst
hat man immer dieses problem dass die
leute mit dem die das kapital besitzen
da er eben ausweichen und dahin gehen wo
die steuer nämlich texten werden jetzt
schauen wir uns mal kurz haben wie das
in der schweiz ist wie das vermögen
verteilt ist und die unia hat zusammen
mit dem gewerkschaftsbund 2015 im rahmen
der erbschaftssteuer initiative eine
animierte grafik erstellt wie eigentlich
das vermögen in der schweiz verteilt ist
und das schauen wir uns zusammen an
in der schweiz sind wir stolz darauf in
einem land zu leben in dem alle die
chance haben durch fleiss und arbeit ein
vermögen aufzubauen und gut zu leben
aber ist das wirklich so neue studien
liefern dazu überraschende erkenntnisse
1009 schweizerinnen und schweizer wurden
dazu befragt wie ist unser vermögen
verteilt nehmen wir an diese 100 figuren
sind wir schweizerinnen und schweizer
die ärmsten ganz links die reichsten
ganz rechts sekretärinnen becker
ärztinnen und ein ceo zusammen besitzen
wir 1500 milliarden franken
wie würden wir dieses vermögen
idealerweise verteilen
die umfrage zeigt wir finden es richtig
dass einige mehr haben als andere
die reichsten 20 prozent sollen etwas
mehr als ein drittel des vermögens
besitzen aber auch die ärmsten besitzen
etwas das finden wir gerecht doch wie
glauben wir dass das vermögen
tatsächlich verteilt ist wir schätzen
das reichste fünftel besitzer rund 57
prozent des schweizer vermögens weit
mehr als in unserer idealvorstellung
diese einschätzung ist aber weit von der
realität entfernt
tatsächlich ist das vermögen extrem
ungleich verteilt
die reichsten 20 besitzenden
allergrößten teil des vermögens sechs
mal mehr als alle anderen zusammen und
die ärmsten haben rein gar nichts
und wie ist es mit den superreichen ihr
vermögen sprengt die grafik 2 prozent
besitzen so viel vermögen wie wir 98
prozent zusammen
[Musik]
die vermögensunterschiede in der schweiz
in massiv grösser als wir glauben und
noch viel größer als wir sie uns
wünschen
ja sie haben eben geschmunzelt aus
dieser grad nach oben ging
überrascht sie das beeindruckt das nicht
mehr kennt ihr diese zu haben ich kenne
ähnliche grafiken und eigentlich
animierte grafiken für die usa und ich
wusste nicht dass schweiz auch soweit
aus den bildrand hinaus ragt aber es
erstaunt mich auch nicht besonders
und es ist glaube ich unglaublich
wichtig dass das bewusstsein über dieses
thema in die öffentlichkeit gelangt denn
wenn man nicht weiß wie ungleich in
folge schafften sind dann hat man auch
nicht den eindruck dass sich da was
anderen müsste und das macht es nicht
leichter sich dann die richtige richtung
zu gast zeigte das video auch oder das
sozusagen die einschätzung wie das
wirklich ist von der realität abweicht
und der idealzustand noch mehr die man
sich wünschen würde und von muss so
gibt's ja diesen satz dass kein bürger
so reich sein sollte das einen anderen
kaufen kann und keiner so arm dass er
sich verkaufen muss und wenn man solche
ungleichheiten sieht fragt man sich halt
schon wie können eigentlich leute aus
der untersten oder aus der obersten
kategorie sich hier auf augenhöhe
begegnen
man kann sich vielleicht
veranschaulichen immer an der frage was
würde denn passieren wenn diese beiden
personen die wir doch mal raus greifen
im gerichtsprozess gegeneinander führen
würden und es kann hier einfach sein
dass aufgrund irgendwelcher
streitigkeiten nachbarschaftsgarten
steuer was auch immer leute sich vor
gericht und optimalerweise idealerweise
ist natürlich so dass vor gericht
wirklich alle gleich behandelt werde
gericht also noch welche die gerichte
sollen unabhängig sein
aber die frage ist eben schaffen sie es
angesichts solcher ungleichheiten die
unabhängigkeit zu bewahren wie ist es
mit den anwälten die man sich leisten
kann die ist es mit den medien an die
man sich gegebenenfalls wenden kann und
was erzeugt das auch für ein selbstbild
bei denen ganz oben und ganz unten wenn
sie wissen es gibt all diese mechanismen
oder anders gesagt können wir die
institutionen unserer gesellschaft die
unabhängig sein sollten also die
gerichte die bildung die medien können
wir die unabhängig halten wenn die
vermögens und einkommens ungleichheit zu
absteigen können wir das ich denke es
gefährlich wir sollten alles zunächst so
weit wie möglich zu verwirklichen
aber es ist ein guter grund dafür auch
die ungleichheit zu begrenzen dann mit
dieser anderen institutionen nicht in
die innere unabhängigkeit gefährdet
werden
es gibt so einen philosophischen autor
den harry frankfurt ein us
amerikanischer philosoph sehr renommiert
da hat kürzlich ein buch geschrieben wo
ältere aufsätze verarbeitet und das
dritten titel ungleichheit warum wir
nicht alle gleich viel haben müssten und
seine these ist das problem ist nicht
die ungleichheit sondern eigentlich dass
die tatsache dass nicht alle genug haben
ungleichheit selbst ist auch kein
problem sagt er aber er meint sie sehen
ein problem hin dass armut gibt und
nicht alle genug haben würden sie dem
zustimmen
ja nein also es stimmt dass der
wichtigste aspekt von ungleichheit der
am dringendsten politisch behandelt
werden muss das ist was im unteren ende
passiert und zwar einfach weil manchen
leuten reale lebenschancen verweigert
werden wenn sie finanziell so schlecht
dastehen im vergleich zum rest der
bevölkerung dass sie einfach bestimmte
optionen überhaupt nicht mehr haben und
auch ihre kinder nicht mehr
gleiche chancen haben so wollten sie
noch genauer drauf kommen
aber das heißt nicht dass wir uns über
die gesamte form der verteilung keine
gedanken machen müssten
denn es ist nun mal so wir leben in
einer gesellschaft zusammen und sehr
viele der prozesse die zum beispiel
bestimmen was häuser kosten was als eine
gute ausbildung gibt gilt wer zu welchem
gesellschaftlichen bereichen zugang hat
diesen sinn auch davon beeinflusst wie
die verteilung insgesamt strukturiert
ist und frankfurt ist in dem sinne zu
abstrakt philosophisch dass er diese
ganze soziologische dimension einfach
nicht berücksichtigt leiden theoretisch
kann man durchaus über diese argumente
reden hauptsache ist wir können die am
unteren rand anheben
aber um das zu tun und das in allen
dimensionen zu tun müssen wir denke ich
auch die gesamtbeurteilung bedachten er
würde auch sagen die in gleicher art
selbst ist moralisch unproblematisch
kein problem aber die folgen kann es
schon sein dass
die chancengleichheit nicht mehr
gewährleistet ist genau und es gibt
studien dazu dass die ungleiche länder
sind umso geringer auch die
chancengleichheit es chancengleichheit
ist relativ schwer zu messen man nimmt
dann oft das verhältnis der personen die
in der gleichen einkommensstufe sind
ihre eltern zu denen die aufgestiegen
sind versucht uns irgendwie zu
kategorisieren und tatsächlich ist es so
je ungleicher länder sind umso
schwieriger ist das ist auch einfach zu
erklären denn je weiter die schere auf
geht umso weiter muss man sozusagen
springen wenn man von weiter unten zu
einem punkt weiter oben kommen will und
auch soziologisch entwickeln sich die
schichten einfach sehr stark auseinander
und das bedeutet dass am ende die kinder
der unterschiedlichen gruppen innerhalb
der skala doch sehr ungleiche chancen
haben
man kann dagegen angehen man kann
versuchen zum beispiel doch gute
öffentliche bildung dem entgegenzuwirken
aber es ist die frage ob man das auf
dauer schafft wenn die ungleichheit
ebenso explodiert über das werden wir
gleich noch sprechen ich möchte noch ein
zweites argument einbringen was
eigentlich für die ungleichheit spricht
und zwar von john rawls einem
amerikanischen gerechtigkeit theoretiker
und der hat ein prinzip aufgestellt das
heißt dass differenz prinzip sagt
ungleichheiten sind manchmal eben auch
gerechtfertigt nämlich dann wenn sie den
schwächsten nützen und die sozusagen
hochziehen und das ganze hat er dafür
hatte argumentiert mit einem
gedankenexperiment dass er berühmt ist
mit dem schleier des nichtwissens und
wir haben im im rahmen von srf kultur
haben wir kleine filme erstellt viel los
so fix heißt die reihe wo wir hat
wichtige gedankenexperimente
illustrierend haben und wir schauen uns
diesen schleier des nichtwissens mal an
die reichsten schweizer nur ein prozent
der bevölkerung besitzen knapp die
hälfte des vermögens aller schweizer
zusammen die chance dass ein akademiker
kind eine hochschule besucht ist in der
schweiz 1,5 mal höher als die eines
nicht akademikerkindern frauen verdienen
in der schweiz für den gleichen job im
schnitt 20 prozent weniger als männer
ist das gerecht wie müsste eine welt
beschaffen sein in der echte
gerechtigkeit herrscht stell dir vor du
kannst gemeinsam mit anderen festlegen
wie eine gerechte gesellschaft
auszusehen hat welche güter verteilt wer
wie wer hat welche rechte wer krieg den
spitzenjobs den nur eine haben kann
was ist ein gerechter lohn
hier diskutiert und diskutiert und
entwirft die gerechte welt damit eure
entscheide nicht parteiisch ausfallen
und ihr nicht einen staat zu euren
gunsten entwerft wird euch ein schleier
des nichtwissens umgebunden hinter dem
schleier wisst ihr nicht werde ich in
dieser welt eine frau sein oder ein mann
werde ich in einer wohlsituierten
akademikerfamilie aufwachsen oder als
kind einer mittellosen migrantenfamilie
lebe ich in der stadt oder auf dem land
ohne oder mit kindern bin ich sportlich
oder eher nicht religiös oder
atheistisch keine ahnung
ihr macht die spielregeln wisst aber
nicht an welcher position er später
spielen werdet in diesem urzustand
werdet ihr euch auf wenige prinzipien
einigen die eine gerechte gesellschaft
ausmachen
das meint john rawls der erfinder dieses
gedankenexperiment er glaubt ihr
entscheidet euch hinter dem schleier des
nichtwissens für eine gesellschaft in
der es den am schlechtesten gestellten
möglichst gut geht denn ihr könntet ja
in dieser position sein
dieses sogenannte differenz prinzip
behauptet selbst ungleichheiten können
gerecht sein nämlich dann wenn sie
denjenigen zugute kommen die am
wenigsten haben
das heißt der ceo einer grossbank darf
sich ohne schlechtes gewissen einem
exorbitanten lohn auszahlen wenn auch
der angestellte am bankschalter mehr
verdient
gegen ungleichheit kann man nichts sagen
solange alle davon profitieren
stimmt das was ist gerecht
[Musik]
tja hat hat er recht hat schon raus gibt
es ungleichheiten die gerechtfertigt
sind
ich fände es differenz prinzip sehr
wichtig aber ich glaube dass es
interpretationsbedürftig ist wenn man es
auf die heutige welt anwendet und das
sehr leicht das ist so missbrauchen um
weit mehr ungleichheit zu rechtfertigen
als tatsächlich damit gerechtfertigt
werden kann und das entscheidende ist
dieses wenn also wenn ungleichheit ein
schlechtes gestellten zugute kommt und
ich sage es wann ist es eigentlich der
fall
das standort argument ist wir müssen den
talentierten mitgliedern der
gesellschaft mehr geld anbieten damit
sie hart arbeiten bestimmte jobs machen
für die sie eine lange ausbildung
brauchen weil dann die gesellschaft als
ganzes profitiert und die frage ist
jetzt wie viel mehr müssen sie dafür
dienen dass das der fall ist
ich glaube nicht das was wir heute an
ungleichheit sehen und die nächste frage
ist ja auch ob sie wirklich so viel mehr
verdienen müssten oder ob nicht auch
andere formen der anreize dazu führen
können dass sie diese leistungen
erbringen diese sozialen beiträge die
andere frage ist noch welche branchen
unserer gesellschaft eigentlich was
leisten und das sind ganz schwierige
diskussionen aber gerade im
finanzbereich kann man sich schon die
frage stellen ob alle dinge die dort
passieren wirklich der gesellschaft als
ganze zugute kommen oder ob da nicht
einiges stärker reguliert werden müsste
machen wir es doch konkret schauen wir
uns die drei top verdiener der schweiz
an sergio ermotti sehe oder ubs 14,3
millionen 2015 verdient was würden sie
sagen da spielte einfach der freie markt
das sind anreize und man würde
wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich sagen nur
so hat man die besten manager diese
position also zum einen ist die frage
was hier qualität eigentlich ausmacht
sind wir doch mal beiseite geschoben
solche preise entstehen im vergleich zu
anderen akteuren und jeder will
natürlich mehr ist die anderen auch wenn
objektiv gesprochen das vielleicht gar
kein unterschied mehr machen würde ob
man jetzt 14 oder zehn oder fünfzehn
millionen hat die frage ist doch leistet
dieser mensch so viel dass wirklich die
schlechteste gestellten in der
gesellschaft was davon haben dass das
rechtfertigen würde das ist so viel mehr
ist als bei anderen und da hätte ich
schon meine großen zweifel und in der
vergangenheit war dieses verhältnis von
höchsten zu durchschnittlich oder auch
zur niedrigsten gehälter in den firmen
auch weitaus kleiner
ich hasse es nicht ob man sagen will die
zielauswahl damals alle foul
aber er ist überzeugt nicht dass die
spaltung so groß sein muss den menschen
schauen ihr relativ auf das was im
vergleich zu anderen verdienen und dafür
muss man die spreizung nicht so weit
aufmachen was wären dann gute kriterien
um jemanden einen besseren lohn zu geben
aus einem anderen das gibt schon bei
einem smith was man da als faktoren
anführen könnte wenn einen job
unangenehmer ist als ein anderer kann
ist die frage müsste er nicht eigentlich
besser bezahlt werden bei uns natürlich
so dass viele jobs die relativ
unangenehm sind von der tätigkeit her
oder einfach langweilig auch die sind
für die es viele bewerber gibt weil man
keine besonders gute ausbildung braucht
und dann drückt das den preis wieder
aber im prinzip aus gerechtigkeit
perspektive müsste man doch sagen die
langweilige körperlich anstrengenden job
ist umso mehr müssten die leute dort
verdienen
aber so ein job ist vielleicht nicht
körperlich anstrengend dafür psychischen
unglaubliche braucht noch im auto tja
und verantwortung ist denke ich schon
auch ein faktor der rechtfertigt dass
jobs etwas besser bezahlt werden aber um
14,3 millionen können wir das noch
irgendwie ihrem verhalten setzen und
warum soll er nicht der freie markt
spielen sie sind eine expertin für vier
märkte warum soll man jetzt da
eingreifen märkte sind ja kein
naturprodukt sondern märkte finden
innerhalb von regeln statt die durch
menschliche gemeinschaften gesetzt
werden gesetze steuerliche regulierungen
alle möglichen faktoren und zu sagen
dass der markt gut funktioniert kann man
eigentlich immer nur innerhalb eines
gewissen gesetzten rahmens und diesen
rahmen kann man auch beeinflussen
um zu sehen wie viel verdient werden
soll ich hatte folgendes beispiel
angesprochen wie viel von
managergehältern eigentlich steuerlich
absetzbar ist
man wird sehen weil das käme ob das
nicht insgesamt die managergehälter
etwas dämpfen würde
vielleicht noch nicht genug aber
vielleicht in die richtige richtung ohne
dass der markt in dem sinne ein geschenk
würde dass man sagt die leute dürfen
nicht mehr frei aushandeln also es geht
um die rahmensetzungen des ganzen und
bislang war das denken oft na ja wir
lassen den freien markt irgendwie
spielen und dann kriegen wir den großen
kuchen und den kuchen verteilen wir dann
durch umverteilung durch steuern aber
beim setzen der regeln für den markt
also beim backen kuchen sozusagen gibt
es ja auch schon regeln die man
beeinflussen kann
und da ist schon die frage ob die im
moment so gestaltet sind dass die
ungleichheiten wieder entstehen so
wirklich notwendig sind oder ob man da
nicht um einiges auch reduzieren könnte
also sie würden sagen diese spielregeln
des kuchen backen
die sind nicht fair ich glaube die sind
verzerrt allein schon deswegen weil die
möglichkeit zu werden doch nur einen
relativ kleinen kreis der bevölkerung
offen steht und auch innerhalb der
jährigen von denen man guten gewissens
sagen könnte die denn kompetenz sondern
job auszuführen ist wirklich die frage
wer von denen hat dann wirklich die
möglichkeit sondern darauf an zu nehmen
also mehr gibt es nicht zu sagen wir
sollen wenig kompetenzen auch würdigen
mir geht's auch nicht so zu sagen dass
alle gleich sind und es gibt
unterschiedliche talente auch
unterschiedliche interessen sondern job
will vielleicht auch nicht jeder aber
solche gehälter scheint mir doch nicht
ausdrückt das so zu sein dass wirklich
jeder eine faire chance hätte sondern
job anzunehmen sonst müsste der preis
eigentlich wieder senken und so viele
bewerber gäbe
lassen sie uns etwas über dieses
verdienen sprechen wer eigentlich was
verdient und wer welche chancen hat sie
selbst in ihrer professorin ist seit
knapp einem jahr in münchen an der
technischen hochschule und die frage ist
kann man reich eine professur verdienen
nein also nicht in dem sinne dass jeder
der das vielleicht gerne würde die
chance hätte philosophie-professor zu
werden
das ist ein job der wahrscheinlich mehr
kandidaten als plätze hat das heißt
begehrt man kann höchstens sagen dass
man diejenigen auswählen sollte die
kompetenz in den job dann auch zu machen
aber die qualitätsstandards die dabei
angewandt werden
die sind auch immer eine sage der
menschlichen wertung der festsetzung
allein schon so dinge wie bewertet man
jetzt forschung und lehre versus andere
aktivitäten und das ist immer up to date
sozusagen und da gibt es nicht den einen
standard nachdem man sagen könnte das
hier ist verdient und das hier ist
unverdient und man muss ja auch immer im
hinterkopf behalten dass ich als
philosophieprofessor an arbeiten kann
geht auch nur weil ganz viele jobs in
der gesellschaft von anderen leuten
gemacht werden und wir diese
arbeitsteilung haben die es jedem von
uns erlaubt sich zu spezialisieren und
eine sache sehr vertieft zu machen aber
letztlich hängen wir unglaublich stark
voneinander ab stellen sie sich mal vor
dass sie es irgendwo hinkommen und ich
vollkommen selbst versorgen müssten also
ich würde gnadenlos scheitern
wie hängen ganz stark voneinander ab und
wir müssten unsere wirtschaft habe ich
viel stärker als einen
gesamtzusammenhang sehen wo wir
gemeinsam etwas tun wo wir gemeinsam an
dingen arbeiten und spezialisieren aber
nicht ständig nur im wettbewerb stehen
sondern uns auch gegenseitig ergänzen
die sind ja philosophen und ökonomen
eine rarität sozusagen gibt es elf
gehört in die wirtschaftswelt überhaupt
zum shared die sich darum was die
philosophen und philosophen sagen ab und
zu würde ich sagen aber doch eher selten
und was ich am deprimierenden befinde
ist es nicht dass sie den philosophen
nicht zuhören sondern dass ich innerhalb
der volkswirtschaftlichen lehre seit der
finanzkrise so wenig geändert hat denn
eigentlich wurden da ganz viele
grundfesten der ökonomischen theorien
die man so hatte erschüttert
das hat einen ganz wenige ökonomen
vorhergesehen dass hier was im busch ist
und trotzdem scheint sich in der lehre
nur ganz wenig zu verändern und so die
die paradigmen die bilder die vermittelt
werden scheinen weitgehend die gleichen
zu bleiben und das ist doch irgendwie
sehr traurig dass dieses feld der
relativ immun gegen veränderungen zu
sein scheint aber es gab doch größere
auflagen für eigenkapital
mehr regulierungen usw es wird ja nicht
einfach nichts können das stimmt aber es
ist in einem sehr minimalen bereich
geblieben
und wenn aus dem kreis der ökonomen
argumente kommen die dinge etwas
radikaler zu verändern zb der vorschlag
von ob martin und hellweg 30 prozent
eigenkapitalquote bei banken zu
verlangen
dann sind die innerhalb ihrer zunft ganz
schön im gegenwind ausgesetzt was man
auch noch thematisieren könnte etwas
heikles thema und das sollte man sich ja
nicht pauschal alle ökonomen verurteilen
aber es gab durchaus einige fälle wo
ökonomen auch einfach sehr eng mit der
finanzindustrie zusammengearbeitet haben
das war so auszudrücken wo sich schon so
ein bisschen die frage stellt wie
unabhängig diese experten dann
eigentlich noch sinn oder wie es der die
positionen vertreten die den geldgebern
ihrer studien- oder sozialen gekommen
was haben und die philosophie für die
ökonomie berg beitragen oder wie sehen
sie persönlich ihre eigene rolle
ich sehe meine rolle sodass ich versuche
meinen studenten und denjenigen in der
öffentlichkeit dieses interessiert
gewisse zusammenhänge zu erklären und
vor allen dingen zu hinterfragen was für
denkmuster und bilder ist mit denen wir
uns bestimmten problemen annehmen denn
diese denkt muss das in extrem
wirkmächtig von keynes gibt's diesen
satz dass viele menschen die praktisch
arbeiten und denken sie hatten keinerlei
ideologie von irgendwelchen toten
akademikern von paar jahrzehnten vorher
beeinflusst wurden und sich darüber klar
zu werden welche bilder welche begriffe
welche die ökonomin uns eigentlich
beeinflussen in unserem handeln und in
unserem denken da kann die verlosung für
einen ganz wichtigen beitrag leisten was
wäre so ein bild das uns gefangen hat
zum beispiel diese ganz starke
dichotomie hier ist der start und hier
ist der markt und die beiden operieren
noch ganz unterschiedlichen prinzipien
oder hier ist die privatwirtschaft und
die staatlichen bürokratien wenn man
anfängt sich das soziologisch
anzuschauen wenn man die begriffe die
verwendet werden etwas hinterfragt sieht
man dass diese beiden sphären im viel
stärker verboten sind das zum beispiel
innerhalb von großen organisationen die
handlungs probleme für leute in der
privatwirtschaft und im öffentlichen
institutionen auf ganz ähnliches sind
und dass uns dieses denkschemata
dieses denkschema markt hier statt da
oft leere führt jetzt haben sie einen
ganz zentralen punkt schon genannt
nämlich dass ungleichheiten dann
problematisch sind wenn sie ungleiche
chancen schaffen und dieses ideal der
chancengleichheit ist etwas das alle von
uns teilen würde ich sagen
[Musik]
ketzerische frage ist das nicht eine
naive vorstellung utopie wir sind doch
zu unterschiedlich wir wachsen in
unterschiedlichen familien auf den
unterschiedlichen ländern haben
unterschiedliche talente werden
unterschiedlich viel haben glück oder
pech ist dass überhaupt ein ideal an
dass man sich annähern an dem man sich
orientieren kann
als wär dann naiv wenn man es zu
verstehen würde das wirklich alle exakt
das gleiche leben führen sollten dann
wäre auch die frage inwieweit das
eigentlich mit individueller freiheit
vereinbar ist sich für unterschiedliche
dinge im leben zu entscheiden aber es so
wird das ja auch selten gemeint sondern
was gemeint ist
das ist dass es vernünftige
möglichkeiten für menschen aus ganz
unterschiedlichen hintergründen geben
sollte über ihr leben entscheiden sich
für bestimmte berufe zu entscheiden und
ihr leben so zu leben wie das möchten
und auch gesellschaftlich aufsteigen zu
können wenn das jeder entscheidung ist
dass sie das machen wollen und da sieht
man doch dass es ziemlich viele
hindernisse gibt und wir sehr sehr weit
von diesem ideal entfernt sind so dass
uns dieses extreme ideal wie es wäre
wenn wirklich perfekte chancengleichheit
herrscht eigentlich nicht so sitzt und
servieren braucht und die wirklichkeit
ist so weit weg von jeder form von
chancengleichheit im moment dass wir uns
darüber vielleicht nicht so viel
gedanken machen sollten von den eher
darüber wie ein bisschen näher an so
eine pragmatische vernünftige form von
chancengleichheit kommen könnten und ein
schlüsselfaktor darf dafür ist die
bildung wie sie selbst sagen und da gibt
es ja wirklich einfach statistiken die
zeigen zum beispiel in der schweiz
wer einen akademiker als vater hat wird
doppelt so häufig an einer universität
studieren wie ein nicht akademiker
wie verhindert man dass was kann man
dagegen tun
also ich denke eine ganz wichtige frage
ist wie gut die öffentlichen schulen die
leute darauf vorbereiten dass mit ihrem
leben zu machen in bezug auf bildung was
sie möchten und wofür sie talent haben
und es ist ja so heutzutage dass
zusätzlich zu den schulischen angebot
mancher eltern eben noch sehr viel
selber investieren in dinge die der
bildung ihrer kinder zu gute kommen
sollen
und diejenigen die das dann nicht machen
können einfach sehr schnell das
nachsehen haben und hier müssten
öffentliche schulen einfach so gut und
auch so gut ausgestattet sein dass das
für alle gleichermaßen der fall ist ein
zweiter faktor ist dass es bei
chancengleichheit auch sehr stark um
soziale kontexte geht darum wie man
kennt wenn man als vorbild hat es wie
man sich in bestimmten kreisen bewegen
kann also das was bei böse das
kulturelle und soziale kapital heißt und
das ist auch ungleich verteilt in
unserer gesellschaft und das können wir
nicht dadurch so leicht umverteilen dass
wir einfach geld um verteilen sondern da
ist die frage was für mentoringprogramme
bieten wir eigentlich an wie kann jemand
aus einer familie die bisher nichts mit
sagen wir medien zu tun hatte was
darüber erfahren was es bedeutet in den
medien zu arbeiten da leute
kennenzulernen sich das anzuschauen
überhaupt festzustellen ob ein imbiss
gefallen würde und dann vielleicht auch
wege in diese richtung zu gehen und da
denke ich ist es auch nur diesen
problemen wenn die gesellschaft
insgesamt ungleicher wird eben weil sich
die schichten weiter voneinander
wegbewegen unsere diese natürlichen
spontanen kontakte die einfach entstehen
können in der nachbarschaft in der
schule wenn da alle kinder gemeinsam
sind wenn die weniger werden dann sinken
die chancen für diejenige im unteren
ende in bezug auf eben sozialkapital um
kulturelles kapital da mitzuhalten mit
denjenigen die privilegierte sind dass
man sie fordern sogar eine frühkindliche
bildung das heißt das ganze fängt schon
viel früher an
es wurde ein kindergarten gleicht vor
der grundschule bei uns primarschule
ja und zwar besonders was die
sprachfähigkeit angeht und das hat viel
auch mit gruppen zu tun die
migrationshintergrund haben wenn die
sprachfähigkeit nicht früh gefördert
wird
ist es ein problem dass die leute
möglicherweise ihr leben lang mit
schleppen und das haben zumindest später
sehr viel schwerer das wieder
auszugleichen und deswegen wäre das ein
punkt wo von staatlicher seite viel
getan werden sollte um zu verhindern
dass hier schon ungleichheit entsteht
natürlich wird man das nicht komplett
machen können konkret was mir das heißt
eine staatliche unterstützung für gute
kitas in deutschland geht es ja sehr in
diese richtung bei ihnen habe ich gehört
noch nicht so sehr um hier einfach nicht
von vornherein so vollkommen
unterschiedliche chancen entstehen zu
lassen es gibt aus england was eine sehr
stark lassen basierte gesellschaft ist
studien dazu wie viele worte kinder aus
der unterschicht und der mittelschicht
in der oberschicht hören bis sie drei
jahre alt sondern das geht schon was ihm
auseinander
um solche phänomene da kann man was
dagegen tun
dann muss man jetzt auch nicht familie
irgendwie abschaffen oder so dass das
zerrbild das manchmal an die wand gemalt
wird sondern da kann man sinnvoll
eingreifen wenn man es will wenn man
bereit ist dafür auch geld in die hand
zu nehmen und viele eltern machen jetzt
hat diese förderung privat wie sie
gesagt haben und dadurch entsteht so
etwas wie ein rattenrennen schreiben sie
in ihrem buch
und dass man zum beispiel die kinder in
die nachhilfe schickt usw
sie selbst haben noch keine kinder frage
was würden sie denn tun um ihr kind zu
fördern wäre das unfair wenn sie
sozusagen ihr gut verdient das geld
investieren würden ihren nachwuchs in
die kinder aber wissen würden dadurch
würden sie auch andere abhängig ist
jetzt steht das ihren riesen dilemma für
die einzelnen und freunde die kinder
haben berichten wir das auch regelmäßig
was spannungen sind denen man da
ausgesetzt ist man muss da glaube ich
unterscheiden zwischen dem individuellen
verhalten und dem was man auch politisch
erreichen kann dann letztlich ist es ja
eine absage des kollektiven handelns wo
das was jeder einzelne für sich für
optimal hält kollektiv ebenso keinem
guten ergebnis führt und das sind fälle
wo man typischerweise staatliche
regulierung braucht das heißt politisch
würde ich mich auf jeden fall ganz stark
dafür einsetzen dass die öffentlichen
schulen in die eben alle gehen können
wirklich so wurzeln dass ich auch guten
gibt es uns mein kind dorthin schicken
kann individuell ist es glaube ich auch
ein bisschen eine frage der einstellung
ob ich
welt zu sehen dass mein kind oder meine
kinder jetzt im wettbewerb mit allen
anderen stehen und auf jeden fall
irgendwie ganz oben auf der leiter
stehen müssen oder ob ich die welt er so
sehr dass diese kinder gemeinsam mit
allen anderen kindern in zukunft
gemeinsam diese gesellschaft bevölkern
werden und an unterschiedlichen stellen
eben zu unserer wirtschaft zu unserer
gesellschaft beitragen werden und wir
letztlich alle interesse daran haben
dass da jeder seinen platz findet und
jeder sich fehr beteiligen kann
und das ändert natürlich die perspektive
darauf wie ich dann auch mit meinen
eigentlich existenten kindern umgehen
würde
neben der bildung gibt es noch einen
anderen faktor nämlich den reichtum den
mann erst oder das vermögen das man erst
jetzt kann man ganz simpel sagen etwas
das man geerbt hat hat man nicht
verdient man ist ja auf die welt
gekommen und hat dieses vermögen schon
wie kann man so etwas wie er denn
überhaupt rechtfertigen vor einem
hintergrund von leistungsgerechtigkeit
dass man das bekommt was man sich
verdient aus der perspektive der
leistungsgerechtigkeit kann man es gar
nicht rechtfertigen aber die steht an
der stelle eben entspannungen mit dem
prinzip dass man sagt familie ist ein
sehr wichtiges gut in der gesellschaft
familien sollen zusammenhalten und
familienmitglieder sollen auch das recht
haben sich gegenseitig gutes zu tun und
natürlich ist die frage wie beckmann
zwischen diesen beiden werten hier ab
und ähnlich wie bei der förderung
dagegen aber das macht es ist ja so da
hat man wirklich sehr große
schwierigkeiten zu sagen man will es den
einzelnen eltern verbieten
wir haben sie im kind vorlesen da geht
es wirklich um soziale beziehungen die
unglaublich wertvoll sind die für alle
sehr bereichernd sind das will man ja eh
nicht so sehr ein regieren das heißt man
sollte sich eher die frage stellen wie
man auf der finanziellen seite
ausgleichen kann denn oft ist es ja
schon so dass diejenigen familien die
ihre kinder nicht finanziellen bereich
gut behandeln können sie auch im
finanziellen bereich dann besser stellen
können nicht immer aber oft und insofern
denke ich dass man eher auf der
finanziellen seite durchaus stark
besteuern sollte und es gibt auch den
vorschlag dass
alle mitglieder einer gesellschaft sagen
wir zum 18
geburtstag mir geht es um ihr geld
bekommen sollten
und diejenigen die erben bekommen die
gleiche summe steuerfrei und alles
drüber wird relativ stark besteuert und
diejenigen die nicht erben bekommen das
vom staat von der gesellschaft um wieder
in gewissen ausgleich zu schaffen und
das finde ich einen sehr interessanten
vorschlag die frage ob so eine
einmalzahlung die optimale möglichkeit
ist oder wie man es dann konkret
gestalten müsste aber auch hier ist das
eben so man kann gesellschaftlich
gestalten und man muss eben
unterschiedliche werte gegeneinander
abwägen und dann einfach gucken wie sich
das bewährt und wo man vielleicht auch
noch mal nachjustieren muss aber sie
würden nicht sagen soll der staat
sozusagen aufoktroyieren sondern das
sind demokratische prozesse man muss die
öffentlichkeit die zivilgesellschaft
überzeugen
bei uns werden solche abstimmungen
manchmal abgelehnt und dann ist es halt
so würden sie sagen
das heißt dass die mehrheit der
bevölkerung oder derjenigen die zwei
gegangenes abstimmung in dem fall von
den argumenten nicht überzeugt ist und
dann muss man sich die frage stellen wie
kann man weiter argumentieren welche
fakten wissen die leute vielleicht eben
auch nicht also die hat der film von
vorhin ist den leuten bewusst wie groß
die ungleichheit ist was für annahmen
haben die leute darüber was für
auswirkungen das hätte und das sind dann
gesellschaftliche prozesse dass man
einerseits auf der ebene der argumente
und andererseits auf der ebene der
fakten einfach argumentiert
überzeugungsarbeit zu leisten versucht
und dann muss man sehen was passiert
jetzt neben den bereichen bildung und
erben gibt es danach die substanz ist
das finanzkapital dass sich das sich
vermehren kann
was hatten sie damals philosophen von
kapitalgewinnsteuer oder
transaktionssteuer alsbald
transaktionssteuern ist ja der gedanke
dass man sozusagen sand ins getriebe
wirft um die ausufernde spekulation
etwas einzudämmen und man dieses geld
das dann doch angenommen wird vielleicht
auch nur sinnvoll einsetzen könnte
und das halte ich in jeder hinsicht für
sinnvoll natürlich muss man gucken wie
ich sein konkret gemacht wird so dass
wirklich alle transaktionen besteuert
werden wenn ich irgendwelche der
zeitungen schafft aber das
philosophische perspektive ist das ein
ende und plausibler vorschlag
ich frage mich jetzt wie rechtfertigt
man das dass man da in ein freies
marktsystem und sind eine spekulation
eingreift und einigen wieder wegnimmt
was ihr euch verdient haben nach den
spielregeln wie sie aussehen
da ist jetzt die frage ob verdient an
der stelle die passende vokabel sind
deutschen es ist ja so dass verdient
einerseits das rein finanzielle meint
wie hoch ist das verdienst und
andererseits immer so eine moralische
komponente hat und ob die bei den
finanzmärkten insbesondere spekulation
angemessen ist könnte man jetzt wirklich
sehr stark hinterfragen aber sie sagten
eingriffen den freien markt das ist
wieder das denken der markt ist da und
im nachhinein greifen wir ein
aber so ist es ja nicht sondern diese
spekulation ist überhaupt nur möglich
weil der staat rechtliche strukturen
bereitstellt weil er ihnen zwar auch
durchsetzt mit öffentlichen gerichten
usw
die es den spekulanten überhaupt erst
erlauben diese ganzen geschäfte zu
unternehmen
und dann diese spielregeln die das
erlauben etwas zu ändern und zu sagen
gut wir erlauben zwar aber wir für eine
gewisse steuer jeweils ab ist einfach
eine änderung der spielregeln und das
sollte man nicht so verstehen dass man
sagt freier markt und wir sollten
möglichst wenig rein gehen sondern
angemessen da ist es eben so zu
beschreiben es gibt spielregeln und wir
müssen uns den gesamteffekt dieser
spielregeln anschauen und bei
spekulation kann man das auch noch so
begründen das ausufernde spekulation oft
riesigen aufbaut die dann zu blasen
führen können oder zu irgendwelchen
anderen verzerrungen die letztlich der
gesellschaft als ganze eigentlich
schaden wie wir 2008 und fast ganz
extreme fall aber auch in anderen fällen
das heißt man hat noch einen
zusätzlichen grund zu sagen an der
stelle sollten wir die spielregeln
verändern
ein vorschlag wäre auch spenden also ist
man die reichsten menschen oder wie
gesehen haben männer der welt am anfang
der sendung etwa bill gates mit seinen
73 milliarden der spendet ja davon 28
knapp 28 milliarden
das hauptsächlich davon ist von diesen
philanthropischen gedanken das empfinde
ich also eine typische zweitbeste lösung
weil die erste lösung in dem fall
steuerung an die spielregeln dies gar
nicht erst entstehen lassen würden
offenbar nicht im griff
hat das problem dass ich bei spenden
sehe ist dass hier einzelnen akteuren
also bill und melinda gates oder anderen
extrem viel macht zukommt
nichtstaatlichen akteuren nicht
staatlichen akteuren aber auch akteuren
die in keinster weise zur verantwortung
gezogen werden können für das was sie
tun höchstens von der öffentlichkeit
wenn es vielleicht ein aufschrei gibt es
in reaktion auf bestimmtes verhalten
aber es gibt ja keine
kontrollmechanismen und das widerspricht
dem gedanken dass in einer freien
gesellschaft alle sich auf augenhöhe
begegnen können und nicht der eine eben
den anderen mit wohltaten überschütten
kann dir auch jederzeit wieder entziehen
kann und damit abhängigkeiten entstehen
die ziemlich problematisch sind in ihrem
buch freiheit gehört nicht nur dann
reichen ein plädoyer von einem
zeitgemäßen liberalismus sagen sie das
selbstbestimmte leben das ist echt der
oberste wert sondern sehr wichtiger wert
und sie sagen es gibt drei freiheiten
einerseits eine negative freiheit dass
man hat nicht irgendwie gehindert wird
ein freies leben zu führen dann eine
positiv das hat man jetzt gehört mit
chancengleichheit dass man sozusagen
überhaupt die möglichkeit hat bestimmte
wege einzuschlagen
und dann sollte er sich eine
republikanische freiheit dass man mit
bestimmende als und ein punkt den ich
ganz interessant fand war dass sie
gesagt haben in der wirtschaft gibt es
diese mitbestimmung eben gerade nicht
oder nicht so stark wie es sie geben
sollte und sie haben gesagt man statt
theidig sozusagen das jetzige system wie
damals aus manchem politischen die
demokratie und die mitbestimmung
einführen worte können sie das kurz
erläutern
ja das stimmt auch von anderen
philosophen nicht nur von mir der
gedanke ist folgender man hat ja immer
dieses bild dass die wirtschaft von
außen gesteuert wird durch demokratische
gesetze das klappt in der globalisierten
welt nicht mehr so gut wie früher als
die nationalstaaten da vielleicht noch
mehr zugriff hatten und die frage ist
sollte nicht ökonomische macht viel
stärker intern innen heraus demokratisch
kontrolliert werden
und es gibt da das sogenannte perel case
argument also man sagt das ist ein
paralleler fall es gibt autorität und in
einer demokratie braucht autorität
demokratische kontrolle
und dann gibt alle möglichen argumente
mit denen leute versuchen zu sagen ja
aber die autorität und der wirtschaft
also dass chefs über den angestellten
oder dass sie aus über den rest der
mannschaft ist anders geartet als die
autorität des staatlichen der
staatlichen regierung und deswegen
greift dieses parallele argumente nicht
ein argument ist zum beispiel dass man
sagt
letztlich sind ja die shareholder die
eigentümer diejenigen dass die das sagen
haben in großen firmen und den link
gehört ja die firma und in der
vergangenheit also wenn ein paar
jahrhunderte zurückgeht wurde auch
argumentiert naja dem fürst oder der
fürstenfamilie gehört ja das ganze land
also es ist wirklich die frage ob das so
einfach gesagt werden kann denen gehört
die firma die investieren in die firma
aber wenn ihr nicht passt was die firma
macht dann können sie auch ihre aktien
verkaufen also die können relativ leicht
sich einfach dem entziehen
während eine angestellte der spezifische
kenntnisse und fähigkeiten entwickeln um
genau in diesen job zu arbeiten
für den das ist möglicherweise viel
schwerer einfach so aus der firma
rauszugehen wenn die dinge die da
entschieden werde nämlich gefallen und
da wird oft gesagt naja die arbeitgeber
die können ja jederzeit wechseln
aber die eigentümer können genauso
leicht oder gleich noch leichter
wechseln
das ist schon die frage wem spricht man
da eigentlich die kontrollfunktion über
die strategischen entscheidungen von
firmen zu das sind wieder macht
ungleichgewichte im spiel und
abhängigkeiten und diese abhängigkeiten
zum schluss noch die sind ja auch ab
globaler ebene seit der globalisierung
und dieses rattenrennen über das wir
gesprochen haben bei der bildung gibt es
einfach global man hat angst abgehängt
zu werden wenn man bestimmte sozialen
standards einhält und andere tun sie
nicht dann haben die wettbewerbsvorteile
und so weiter wie geht man damit um wie
schafft man also letztlich darf man
wahrscheinlich globale regelung ist ja
am anfang gesagt haben wie setzt man das
wird eine ganz schwierige frage im
moment aber teilweise hat das ja auch in
ellwangen hat funktioniert und wir haben
tatsächlich ein nicht zu
unterschätzendes maß an gemeinsamen
regeln zum beispiel die wto standards
die frage ist wie magnesium verändern
genau und die frage ist auch sollten wir
das was in der globalen wirtschaft
passiert wirklich so konzeptionelle
sehen wie sie das sie es beschrieben
haben eben als entenrennen wo es
letztlich immer nur darum geht oben zu
sein der das ist ja so dass höchst
ausschütten ist in welchem maß steigen
der wohlstand einer bestimmten schwelle
oft werden also 70.000 dollar
jahreseinkommen pro person angegeben
die leute noch zu einem besseren leben
befähigt und wirklich glücklicher macht
dazu kommt dass noch die ganze thematik
klimawandel könnte man jetzt auch lange
darauf eingehen die frage ist wirklich
sollten wir dieses denkmodell dass wir
alle möglichst schneller wachsen müssten
als die anderen weiter in die zukunft
tragen oder müsste das nicht viel
stärker darum gehen dass wir uns fragen
was macht eigentlich in unserem land
gutes leben aus wie können wir das der
gesamten bevölkerung ermöglichen und was
bedeutet dass dafür wie wir uns auf dem
globalen markt positionieren also welche
industrien wie bei uns haben usw
sie sind eine junge nie wieder so viel
und setzen auch an diesen hoffnung auf
die generation way auf die generation y
warum ich habe den eindruck dass der
glaube daran dass geld verdienen
glücklich macht abnimmt
es gibt ja einen jugendstudien immer
wieder die aussage dass den leuten
familie freundschaften freizeit um
einiges wichtiger geworden sind und
vielleicht gelingt es sich ein stück
weit eben genau von dieser ratten oder
eine mentalität ich muss aber mehr
verdienen als die anderen zu lösen und
etwas stärker qualitative faktoren mit
zu beachten wie gut ist eigentlich die
arbeit ich mache trage ich hier wirklich
sinnvoll zur gesellschaft bei was
bedeutet das für mein gesamtes leben und
wie lebe ich mit dem leicester
gesellschaft zu sammeln und ist es nicht
auch ein ganz wichtiger faktor dass die
gesellschaft insgesamt zusammenhält und
einigermaßen gerecht ist dieser herzog
vielen herzlichen dank für dieses
gespräch
danke ihnen noch
nächste woche ist es wieder zeit für den
philosophischen stammtisch meine
kollegin barbara bleisch diskutiert die
frage wie wir kinder machen dürfen was
meinen sie
ist es in ordnung wenn 60-jährige babys
kriegen sind genetische untersuchungen
eine erleichterung für werdende eltern
oder erhöhen sie den druck das perfekte
kind zu kriegen
schreiben sie uns ihre meinung auf
facebook oder per e mail
und jetzt gleich sternstunde kunst mit
einem film über den tschechischen
regisseur und oscar preisträger ihre ski
menzel der zeigt warum es gar nicht
lustig ist eine komödie zu drehen
genießen sie den sonntag
[Musik]